you
voters in New Hampshire and Iowa put
Bernie Sanders in Pete Buddha judge
ahead of everybody else in the
Democratic presidential race so far here
to break down the results from
yesterday's primary two of our CBS News
political contributors as Democratic
strategist Jamal Simmons he worked for
president Jim all Simons and he advised
President Barack Obama's 2008 campaign
at Robby Mook we know him well - ran
Hillary Clinton's 2016 presidential
campaign they both join us at the table
let's start with last night guys because
it was a good night for boo to judge and
Sanders but this is in no way a
two-person race at this time so what did
what does New Hampshire say to you yeah
well first of all Bernie didn't you know
run away with it right it was a pretty
close margin and look he did you know
around half of what he did four years
ago but the key is that was enough to
win and to your point if this is a
two-person race the dynamic totally
changes if I'm Bernie Sanders right now
I want to keep this field wide so that
if I'm getting that 25 to 30 percent of
the vote that's enough but they're
saying he got the majority of the
Hispanic vote in New Hampshire less
which is I I don't think it's a big
sample size I did bigger sample size in
Nevada you know this was a spades game
I'd say he's get three in a possible
right we're down to Bernie
we got Bernie we got Budaj we also have
Amy Klobuchar we can't right out of this
is that a surprise for you guys you did
a good job and then the possible would
be Bloomberg real coming so what you
know Amy a surprise though for us she
was a surprise at Iowa right but you
started to see the movement and there's
been some evidence of this that New
Hampshire has a penchant for rallying
around women candidates you know they've
rallied around Hillary Clinton in 2008
they had jeanne Shaheen who was governor
senator they had Maggie Hassan so like
people who was governor they they New
Hampshire has a habit of voting for
women right and so the question was I
think a lot of people thought it was
with Warren it was gonna be that way and
it turned out it wasn't Elizabeth Warren
it was Amy Klobuchar and that way I
think was a little bit more of a
surprise so you've got two candidates
now Budaj edge and Klobuchar who are
ascendant in the moderate section of the
party and Bloomberg entering on Super
Tuesday as this campaign
without a lot the Klobuchar and Buddha
judge have the infrastructure and the
money to compete on a broader scale I
mean I was looking at some numbers back
in October
Amy Klobuchar has 0 field offices in
South Carolina
she had 0 field offices in Nevada so I
assume she's built that up since October
but she doesn't have that much money as
the end of January so we have 5 million
dollars cash on hand so I assume she's
putting staff and people on the ground
but that means that they're just getting
started when you look at people like
Buddha judge and Bernie Sanders they've
been doing this for months Bernie Stan's
been doing it for years so that's a
tough it's a tough fight quite
remarkably two names that we haven't
been talking about what I thought we
might have been would be Warren and
Biden know you want to five six months
ago they would been 1/2 in people's
minds now they're four or five what's
their future as this race broadens I
think it's really tough and I think the
problem for Biden was his whole race was
predicated on winning I can win against
Donald Trump I restore everything that's
been taken away you know from our
country the kind of leadership we had
and he came in so far behind in Iowa and
he came in so far behind last night I
think that message isn't ringing true
Robbie in South Carolina I think he's
expecting himself is right and they keep
saying look we've got we've got
communities of color that are gonna be
voting in a real way it's to the
african-american vote is 2/3 of the vote
in South Carolina yeah we'll have to
just see but I honestly believe I think
these voters are gonna be practical and
I think if you can't win people are
gonna go elsewhere and we're already
seeing Bloomberg and it's according to
the polls pulling a bunch of that
african-american support does that
surprise you Jamel the Bloomberg is
pulling African work yeah surprising I
mean I think the thing that we know
about Bloomberg you think you don't live
in New York know about him is this idea
of stop and frisk and what he didn't
from a justice reform yesterday we all
got hit with this audio tape of
Bloomberg actually saying throat we
should have thrown more people up
against the wall and the rest of more
people release our that tape though very
suspicious you know this is politics and
so that's this is when these things
happen is how it happens
so that's surprising but I think a lot
of African Americans want to beat Donald
Trump and so they're looking for the
candidate who's going to be the
strongest candidate to take Trump on and
in Bloomberg gives that guy
I think that they're more open to it
then we may have thought a month
certainly the Rope enjoy than I thought
at month or six weeks ago the voters
already knew about the stop and frisk or
many of whom did does the audio change
things or is it just sort of like an
underscore of what we already knew to be
the case honestly I don't know if it
does I mean remember with Joe Biden we
had the busing incident this is the man
who led the crime bill with Hillary
Clinton there was a lot of talk about
the crime bill I think voters just sort
of reinforced with Jamal said they want
to win he are gonna go to the person
they think can win Pete Buddha judge
seems to have a problem with black
voters why do you think that is so I
would listen I think when Bill Clinton
ran for president in 1992 he was
considered a conservative they had union
problems all that in Arkansas but every
african-american who knew him in
Arkansas said he was the greatest thing
British person that they knew and he had
a network built around the country you
know you know Buddha just doesn't really
have that kind of a network or those
validators orange Amal Rafi thank you
very much
we'll be right back you're watching CBS
this morning